So, I guess it is a result
of globalization
that you can find Coca-Cola tins
on top of Everest
and a Buddhist monk in Monterey.
(Laughter)
And so I just came,
two days ago, from the Himalayas
to your kind invitation.
So I would like to invite you, also,
for a while, to the Himalayas themselves.
And to show the place
where meditators, like me,
who began with being a molecular biologist
in Pasteur Institute,
and found their way to the mountains.
So these are a few images
I was lucky to take and be there.
There's Mount Kailash
in Eastern Tibet -- wonderful setting.
This is from Marlboro country.
(Laughter)
This is a turquoise lake.
A meditator.
This is the hottest day of the year
somewhere in Eastern Tibet, on August 1.
And the night before, we camped,
and my Tibetan friends said,
"We are going to sleep outside."
And I said, "Why? We have
enough space in the tent."
They said, "Yes, but it's summertime."
(Laughter)
So now, we are going
to speak of happiness.
As a Frenchman, I must say
that there are
a lot of French intellectuals
that think happiness
is not at all interesting.
(Laughter)
I just wrote an essay on happiness,
and there was a controversy.
And someone wrote an article saying,
"Don't impose on us
the dirty work of happiness."
(Laughter)
"We don't care about being happy.
We need to live with passion.
We like the ups and downs of life.
We like our suffering because it's so good
when it ceases for a while."
(Laughter)
This is what I see from the balcony
of my hermitage in the Himalayas.
It's about two meters by three,
and you are all welcome any time.
(Laughter)
Now, let's come
to happiness or well-being.
And first of all, you know,
despite what the French intellectuals say,
it seems that no one wakes up
in the morning thinking,
"May I suffer the whole day?"
(Laughter)
Which means that somehow,
consciously or not,
directly or indirectly,
in the short or the long term,
whatever we do, whatever we hope,
whatever we dream --
somehow, is related to a deep, profound
desire for well-being or happiness.
As Pascal said,
even the one who hangs himself,
somehow, is looking
for cessation of suffering.
He finds no other way.
But then, if you look
in the literature, East and West,
you can find incredible diversity
of definition of happiness.
Some people say, I only believed
in remembering the past,
imagining the future, never the present.
Some people say happiness is right now;
it's the quality of the freshness
of the present moment.
And that led Henri Bergson,
the French philosopher, to say,
"All the great thinkers of humanity
have left happiness in the vague
so that each of them
could define their own terms."
Well, that would be fine if it was just
a secondary preoccupation in life.
But now, if it is something
that is going to determine
the quality of every instant of our life,
then we better know what it is,
have some clearer idea.
And probably, the fact
that we don't know that is why, so often,
although we seek happiness,
it seems we turn our back to it.
Although we want to avoid suffering,
it seems we are running
somewhat towards it.
And that can also come
from some kind of confusions.
One of the most common ones
is happiness and pleasure.
But if you look at
the characteristics of those two,
pleasure is contingent upon time,
upon its object,
upon the place.
It is something that -- changes of nature.
Beautiful chocolate cake:
first serving is delicious,
second one not so much,
then we feel disgust.
(Laughter)
That's the nature of things.
We get tired.
I used to be a fan of Bach.
I used to play it on the guitar, you know.
I can hear it two, three, five times.
If I had to hear it 24 hours,
non-stop, it might be very tiring.
If you are feeling very cold,
you come near a fire, it's so wonderful.
After some moments,
you just go a little back,
and then it starts burning.
It sort of uses itself
as you experience it.
And also, again, it can --
also, it's something that you --
it is not something
that is radiating outside.
Like, you can feel intense pleasure
and some others around you
can be suffering a lot.
Now, what, then, will be happiness?
And happiness, of course, is such
a vague word, so let's say well-being.
And so, I think the best definition,
according to the Buddhist view,
is that well-being is not just
a mere pleasurable sensation.
It is a deep sense
of serenity and fulfillment.
A state that actually pervades
and underlies all emotional states,
and all the joys and sorrows
that can come one's way.
For you, that might be surprising.
Can we have this kind of well-being
while being sad?
In a way, why not?
Because we are speaking
of a different level.
Look at the waves coming near the shore.
When you are at the bottom
of the wave, you hit the bottom.
You hit the solid rock.
When you are surfing on the top,
you are all elated.
So you go from elation
to depression -- there's no depth.
Now, if you look at the high sea,
there might be beautiful,
calm ocean, like a mirror.
There might be storms,
but the depth of the ocean
is still there, unchanged.
So now, how is that?
It can only be a state of being,
not just a fleeting emotion, sensation.
Even joy -- that can be
the spring of happiness.
But there's also wicked joy,
you can rejoice in someone's suffering.
So how do we proceed
in our quest for happiness?
Very often, we look outside.
We think that if we could gather
this and that, all the conditions,
something that we say,
"Everything to be happy --
to have everything to be happy."
That very sentence already reveals
the doom, destruction of happiness.
To have everything.
If we miss something, it collapses.
And also, when things go wrong,
we try to fix the outside so much,
but our control
of the outer world is limited,
temporary, and often, illusory.
So now, look at inner conditions.
Aren't they stronger?
Isn't it the mind that translates
the outer condition
into happiness and suffering?
And isn't that stronger?
We know, by experience,
that we can be
what we call "a little paradise,"
and yet, be completely unhappy within.
The Dalai Lama was once in Portugal,
and there was a lot of construction
going on everywhere.
So one evening, he said,
"Look, you are doing all these things,
but isn't it nice, also,
to build something within?"
And he said, "[Without] that --
even if you get a high-tech flat
on the 100th floor of a super-modern
and comfortable building,
if you are deeply unhappy within,
all you are going to look for
is a window from which to jump."
So now, at the opposite,
we know a lot of people who,
in very difficult circumstances,
manage to keep serenity, inner strength,
inner freedom, confidence.
So now, if the inner conditions
are stronger --
of course, the outer
conditions do influence,
and it's wonderful to live
longer, healthier,
to have access to information, education,
to be able to travel, to have freedom.
It's highly desirable.
However, this is not enough.
Those are just auxiliary, help conditions.
The experience that translates
everything is within the mind.
So then, when we ask oneself
how to nurture
the condition for happiness,
the inner conditions, and which are those
which will undermine happiness.
So then, this just needs
to have some experience.
We have to know from ourselves,
there are certain states of mind
that are conducive to this flourishing,
to this well-being,
what the Greeks called
eudaimonia, flourishing.
There are some which are adverse
to this well-being.
And so, if we look
from our own experience,
anger, hatred, jealousy, arrogance,
obsessive desire, strong grasping,
they don't leave us in such a good state
after we have experienced it.
And also, they are detrimental
to others' happiness.
So we may consider that the more
those are invading our mind,
and, like a chain reaction,
the more we feel miserable,
we feel tormented.
At the opposite,
everyone knows deep within
that an act of selfless generosity,
if from the distance, without anyone
knowing anything about it,
we could save a child's life,
make someone happy.
We don't need the recognition.
We don't need any gratitude.
Just the mere fact of doing that
fills such a sense of adequation
with our deep nature.
And we would like to be
like that all the time.
So is that possible,
to change our way of being,
to transform one's mind?
Aren't those negative emotions,
or destructive emotions,
inherent to the nature of mind?
Is change possible in our emotions,
in our traits, in our moods?
For that we have to ask,
what is the nature of mind?
And if we look from
the experiential point of view,
there is a primary
quality of consciousness
that's just the mere fact
to be cognitive, to be aware.
Consciousness is like a mirror
that allows all images to rise on it.
You can have ugly faces,
beautiful faces in the mirror.
The mirror allows that,
but the mirror is not tainted,
is not modified,
is not altered by those images.
Likewise, behind every single thought
there is the bare consciousness,
pure awareness.
This is the nature.
It cannot be tainted intrinsically
with hatred or jealousy because then,
if it was always there --
like a dye that would permeate
the whole cloth --
then it would be found
all the time, somewhere.
We know we're not always angry,
always jealous, always generous.
So, because the basic
fabric of consciousness
is this pure cognitive quality
that differentiates it from a stone,
there is a possibility for change
because all emotions are fleeting.
That is the ground for mind training.
Mind training is based on the idea
that two opposite mental factors
cannot happen at the same time.
You could go from love to hate.
But you cannot, at the same time,
toward the same object,
the same person, want to harm
and want to do good.
You cannot, in the same gesture,
shake hand and give a blow.
So, there are natural
antidotes to emotions
that are destructive
to our inner well-being.
So that's the way to proceed.
Rejoicing compared to jealousy.
A kind of sense of inner freedom
as opposite to intense
grasping and obsession.
Benevolence, loving kindness
against hatred.
But, of course, each emotion then
would need a particular antidote.
Another way is to try to find
a general antidote to all emotions,
and that's by looking at the very nature.
Usually, when we feel annoyed,
hatred or upset with someone,
or obsessed with something,
the mind goes again
and again to that object.
Each time it goes to the object,
it reinforces that obsession
or that annoyance.
So then, it's a self-perpetuating process.
So what we need to look for now is,
instead of looking outward,
we look inward.
Look at anger itself.
It looks very menacing,
like a billowing monsoon cloud
or thunderstorm.
We think we could sit on the cloud,
but if you go there, it's just mist.
Likewise, if you look
at the thought of anger,
it will vanish like frost
under the morning sun.
If you do this again
and again, the propensity,
the tendencies for anger to arise again
will be less and less
each time you dissolve it.
And, at the end, although it may rise,
it will just cross the mind,
like a bird crossing the sky
without leaving any track.
So this is the principal of mind training.
Now, it takes time,
because it took time for all those faults
in our mind, the tendencies, to build up,
so it will take time
to unfold them as well.
But that's the only way to go.
Mind transformation --
that is the very meaning of meditation.
It means familiarization
with a new way of being,
new way of perceiving things,
which is more in adequation with reality,
with interdependence, with the stream
and continuous transformation,
which our being and our consciousness is.
So, the interface with cognitive science,
since we need to come to that,
it was, I suppose, the subject of --
we have to deal in such a short time --
with brain plasticity.
The brain was thought
to be more or less fixed.
All the nominal connections,
in numbers and quantities,
were thought, until the last 20 years,
to be more or less fixed
when we reached adult age.
Now, recently, it has been found
that it can change a lot.
A violinist, as we heard, who has done
10,000 hours of violin practice,
some area that controls the movements
of fingers in the brain changes a lot,
increasing reinforcement
of the synaptic connections.
So can we do that with human qualities?
With loving kindness,
with patience, with openness?
So that's what those great
meditators have been doing.
Some of them who came to the labs,
like in Madison, Wisconsin,
or in Berkeley,
did 20 to 40,000 hours of meditation.
They do, like, three years' retreat,
where they do meditate 12 hours a day.
And then, the rest of their life,
they will do three or four hours a day.
They are real Olympic
champions of mind training.
(Laughter)
This is the place where the meditators --
you can see it's kind of inspiring.
Now, here with 256 electrodes.
(Laughter)
So what did they find?
Of course, same thing.
The scientific embargo --
a paper has been submitted to "Nature,"
hopefully, it will be accepted.
It deals with the state of compassion,
unconditional compassion.
We asked meditators, who have
been doing that for years and years,
to put their mind in a state
where there's nothing but loving kindness,
total availability to sentient being.
Of course, during the training,
we do that with objects.
We think of people suffering,
of people we love,
but at some point, it can be
a state which is all pervading.
Here is the preliminary result,
which I can show
because it's already been shown.
The bell curve shows 150 controls,
and what is being looked at
is the difference between the right
and the left frontal lobe.
In very short, people
who have more activity
in the right side of the prefrontal cortex
are more depressed, withdrawn.
They don't describe
a lot of positive affect.
It's the opposite on the left side:
more tendency to altruism,
to happiness, to express,
and curiosity and so forth.
So there's a basic line for people.
And also, it can be changed.
If you see a comic movie,
you go off to the left side.
If you are happy about something,
you'll go more to the left side.
If you have a bout of depression,
you'll go to the right side.
Here, the -0.5 is the full
standard deviation
of a meditator
who meditated on compassion.
It's something that is totally out
of the bell curve.
So, I've no time to go
into all the different scientific results.
Hopefully, they will come.
But they found that --
this is after three and a half hours
in an fMRI,
it's like coming out of a space ship.
Also, it has been shown in other labs --
for instance,
Paul Ekman's labs in Berkeley --
that some meditators are able, also,
to control their emotional response
more than it could be thought.
Like the startle experiments, for example.
If you sit a guy on a chair
with all this apparatus
measuring your physiology,
and there's kind of a bomb that goes off,
it's such an instinctive response that,
in 20 years, they never saw
anyone who would not jump.
Some meditators,
without trying to stop it,
but simply by being completely open,
thinking that that bang is just going
to be a small event like a shooting star,
they are able not to move at all.
So the whole point of that is not,
sort of, to make, like,
a circus thing of showing exceptional
beings who can jump, or whatever.
It's more to say
that mind training matters.
That this is not just a luxury.
This is not a supplementary
vitamin for the soul.
This is something
that's going to determine
the quality of every instant of our lives.
We are ready to spend 15 years
achieving education.
We love to do jogging, fitness.
We do all kinds of things
to remain beautiful.
Yet, we spend surprisingly little time
taking care of what matters most --
the way our mind functions --
which, again, is the ultimate thing
that determines
the quality of our experience.
Now, compassion
is supposed to be put in action.
That's what we try to do
in different places.
Just this one example
is worth a lot of work.
This lady with bone TB,
left alone in a tent,
was going to die with her only daughter.
One year later, how she is.
Different schools and clinics
we've been doing in Tibet.
And just, I leave you
with the beauty of those looks
that tells more about happiness
than I could ever say.
(Laughter)
And jumping monks of Tibet.
Flying monks.
Thank you very much.